alright here's the host of NAT GL
Startalk whose latest bestseller is
letters from an astrophysicist Neil
deGrasse Tyson
[Applause]
never disappoint I yeah I'm glad you
never disappoint what the tough universe
how many universe ties do you how about
like trump has all the red ones you have
only occasionally wears a blue one I
have notice but right but not as often
as he wears a red tie but this time I
have about 109 Wow yeah you know it
right there what about a hundred sorry
yeah could be a hundred and eleven oh it
was exactly a hundred no your book is so
interesting I noticed a lot of the
letters that people write you and this
is a lot of it you know you cared about
you're very good with your fans yeah
well I don't know what they think what I
was doing under the hood for decades
while I had this public persona of
talking about the universe there's right
personal private things that issues that
people had and they wrote to me about it
okay and one of the big ones that you
get is people are asking you to sort of
mediate between gosh I want to believe
in God but I don't want to not believe
in science is there way we can square
that circle what did I get a lot I get a
lot of those letters and what do you
tell them I like the way to square that
circle is very mathematical living
congratulations so what happens is I
think people might be raised in one or
another religious tradition and then
they start learning science then they
find places where the science conflicts
and I think most people have never met a
scientist much less now claimed one as
their friend so they see me kind of as
their friend who could then offer
perspective or at least shine some kind
of cosmic luminosity on what next
decision they want to make about how to
reconcile or not their religious
traditions with science enlightened
religious people don't have an issue you
know if Jesus is your Savior no one is
going to take that away from you in a
country that protects the free
expression of religion but if you're
going to come around and say my
religious text tells me the universe is
6,000 years old and I'm gonna stick it
in your science classroom I have an
issue with that right yeah right yeah
[Applause]
basically saying I'm coming down on this
I decide however [ __ ] however when I
people write to me I see it as a
contract of communication right if I
just speak and not care where they're
coming from
then I'm just lecturing you're letting
them down nice it's like you know what
people sudden I say they'll love this in
the red they say everything happens for
a reason
we always think of you because I like
that is so [ __ ] stupid yeah it is
random right we create reason in it
also it's elitist because it's something
you can say when you live in an affluent
society where you have a lot of mm you
know enough money to change jobs or meet
new people you live in a city there's
like a billion people live on a [ __ ]
pile every day and nothing happens for a
reason for them they're born into
grinding party and they die in
definitely an elitist point of view
thank what I wanted to say so I just
wanted to say that the contract I have
it's an unstated contract between those
me and those who write to me is that I
will care about where they're coming
from and how they're thinking and what
receptors they might have for argument's
I might present so for example in the
case of the religious letters I say
there are three truths in the world
there's your personal truth no one's
going to take that from you Jesus is
your Savior Mohammed is your last
prophet these are truths no one is going
to take that from you then there's like
a political truth
that's just what becomes true when it's
repeated enough times okay but then
there's the objective I for those first
two you just which of the methods and
tools of science are invented and
designed to establish right those are
true whether or not you believe in them
and so I say you can keep your six
thousand year universe but understand
that that's a personal truth that you
get from your personal religion if you
rise to power and have control over laws
and legislations in a pluralistic land
it is a recipe for disaster if you're
going to take your personal truths and
create laws that have to then apply to
so the world is is not 6,000 years old
right
it is so not 6,000 years old yeah yeah
so we used to just have to deal with
that in the last few years we've also
had to deal with people who think it
might be flat yeah I am which is stupid
so so I I've said this before I think
the the rise of the flat earthers is
evidence of two things one we live in a
country that protects free speech - we
have a failure of our educational system
so I turn around back to the school
system is a where has it failed in such
a way that a full-grown adult coming out
of this system can't think that the
earth is flat that's where I'm foci
agree right and so you're on the side of
a fact is a fact get over it
I'm on the side that earth is round yes
facts can be anywhere it's this
collection of facts which when put
together in wise and sage ways become
knowledge but so I'd rather speak of
knowledge reppin facts but I bring this
up because I've gotten to some hot water
recently there was a mass shooting you
tweeted something about it which was
true yeah okay if we're gonna be facts
or facts in people I defended you by the
way yeah I did catch that online yeah I
caught that well where was my thank you
so okay anyway my point being what you
said was true yes okay you weren't
trying to hurt you even said the us a
horrific lila you went out of your way
to be nice about it and then said but
the fact is that on average of course
any 48 hours we lose 500 to medical
errors 300 of the flu blah blah blah our
emotions respond more to spectacle than
to data now I know what it's like to
have the Twitter mob come after you I
don't blame you for Apollo it have to do
but you were right facts matter that
they do matter however so do emotions we
are emotion we're an emotional species
so so so where I could do that again I
would have put some touch some some
distance time distance between that
tweet so because people are bereaved
right and so I wanted to have some
retrospectively that's what I would have
done all right I want to ask about an
explorer because I know you want to go
to Mars we're not gonna have that fight
again as we always do Oh get me started
I don't get it started I know Mars in
the face right there talk about a
[ __ ] country bar is the same I mean
honestly if we're gonna make alright
we're not gonna have that argument but
so you admired the explorers as we all
do we had Columbus Day earlier this week
okay
an explorer extraordinaire you would
agree we would all agree as an explorer
important tix work yes sure yes yeah or
else we'd be doing this show in
Barcelona and I mean the balls to get on
the ocean when they did they thought it
was flat the world but not him he was
smart enough to know yeah would that the
world was not what's not was not quiet
yeah but still in that little rickety
boat it's less the size of it it's like
the size of this room and it took its
audacity unbelievable
so was he an ass and gonads yes you know
probably to have that kind of balls
you're not gonna be mr. nice guy all the
time so of course a lot of people say we
should tear down his statues and blah
blah blah because he brought diseases
and he did I read in Jill Lepore his
book Haiti had three million people
before the Europeans came and then it
was 5,000 so okay disease he didn't try
to do that and then slaves he took
slaves but so did our founding fathers
the Bible is cool with slaves neither
Jesus nor his dad God are against them
[Laughter]
it's not his dad I'm not touching this
one I'm just saying he was a 15th
century man the founders had slaves the
Bible had slaves are Kelly still has
them
[Applause]
Columbus Day way in disgust I'm not
touching this one either we need to be
aware of the past of past atrocities and
we need to be sensitive to it but I
think what they weren't we're almost
overdosing on history we're mining the
past constantly for fresh out yes
I don't think Christopher Columbus
should be canceled I think we have a
society that's mature enough to handle
moral ambiguity nice be here yes you
know the Queen Isabella and King
Ferdinand mm-hmm sent the man to the New
World
okay and the game of satchel of flags
that were Spanish flags and put them
wherever you come so I don't know why
Columbus State to this day is celebrated
by Italians they had nothing to do with
his voyage it should be sent and if they
did more people than just a few in
Brooklyn would be speaking Italian in
the Western Hemisphere
you